these men are on the hunt to find the
best spot for watching birds in Uganda
the paddle quietly through the marshes
along Lake Victoria and then a
spectacular find a rare Shoebill stork
standing in the grass the Shoebill is a
threatened species wildlife experts
estimate there are under 1000 left in
Uganda today you go on the highway there
is nothing to tell you anything about
that birds are here or there or so
animals if there's a good good marketing
good tourism for buds uganda needs to do
better because they have such beautiful
birds yeah they hate the world needs to
know and where to go a new smartphone
app helps visitors find Uganda's most
elusive feathered creatures it provides
tips about the best places to look for
popular species like the crested crane
the country's national bird these
crested crane live near the city of cos
Oro in the West but if you want to see
an african fish eagle you will have to
go further north to the river nile
uganda is home to over 1,000 types of
birds including waterfowl like african
jacana
and tree-dwelling cormorants you can
never find this richness anyway we have
got more species per square meter that
any other part of the world the local
tourism industry hopes Uganda's
abundance of wildlife can help attract
more visitors bird watchers are sure to
see some beautiful and rare birds like
the Malachi Kingfisher or it's less
colorful cousin the black-and-white pied